[Música]
já pararam para pensar que algumas
atitudes que a gente toma são muitas
vezes influenciadas por pessoas
importantes em nossa vida que a gente
nem percebe isso
antes de contar uma história eu queria
propor um exercício a vocês pensem por
um instante na pessoa que mais
influenciou na vida e na carreira na
forma com que você toma decisões e pensa
também no momento com essa pessoa e faça
uma relação com alguma decisão que você
tenha tomado recentemente vão pensar no
pai e na mãe num professor num colega no
ídolo pensa em uma referência pra vocês
quando fiz exercício eu pensei no meu
pai meu pai era um vendedor vendedor
nato ele comemorava
sempre que ele fazia uma venda ele
viajava quase toda semana ele tinha uma
caminhonete e eu me lembro do barulho da
caminhonete saindo às 34 da manhã e lá e
meu pai para mais uma viagem em busca de
novos clientes novas vendas
ele sempre voltava cheio de história ele
contava de uma forma lúdica em quais
cidades ele tinha passado quanto ele
tinha vendido se ele já tinha pedido
para a próxima viagem tudo isso enquanto
a família estava em volta da mesa
comendo um docinho pé de moleque que ele
trazia da estrada
ele tem um caderninho eu passava limpo
informações sobre os clientes quem tinha
comprado o preço de venda a preço de
custo
se o cliente tinha algum apelido se
preferia ser visitado de manhã e de
tarde fim do mês
desde criança meu pai me ensinou a
importância de ter uma boa relação com
os clientes de entender bem o seu
cliente tem uma outra referência que a
minha mãe falando que o leme da minha
vida está comigo e eu sou o responsável
por direcionar minha vida
então eu cresci nesse contexto
eu fui ensinado que empreender é uma
missão muito nobre
eu me formei em engenharia seguir uma
carreira tradicional
até que um dia resolvi largar tudo para
abrir uma empresa ou de contas como
minha mãe dizia o leme da minha vida
deveria estar comigo quando eu entrei
nessa jornada
eu errei muito e eu aprendi muito
eu vi que a força do exemplo é
fundamental para o empreendedor
eu aprendi também que ter uma boa rede
de apoio saber assumir os riscos e ter
muita resiliência também são
fundamentais para o empreendedor
junto com meu irmão eu sou co fundador
de uma startup é uma empresa de
inteligência de dados que usa tecnologia
de ponta para ajudar grandes empresas a
se relacionar melhor com seus clientes a
entenderem melhor os seus clientes
lembram do caderninho do meu pai desde o
início dessa jornada
eu vi a importância de ter uma boa rede
de apoio a pessoas confiáveis a seu
redor
eu tenho a sorte de vir de uma família
que admira incentivar o empreendedorismo
e também tem a sorte de dividir esse
sonho com o cara que eu admiro e confio
muito que o meu irmão
empreender é uma questão de propósito
você abre mão de resultado no curto
prazo em prol de um objetivo maior
e foi pensando nisso que alguns anos
atrás eu resolvi largar o emprego que eu
tinha pra embarcar nessa jornada e me
tornar co fundador de uma startup
agora imaginem só no mesmo momento de
largar o emprego pegar todo o dinheiro
investido um negócio novo começar uma
empresa tirar um projeto do papel como
se tudo isso já não fosse dor de cabeça
o suficiente eu resolvi me casar e aí eu
vi que resiliência mesmo quem teve uma
esposa pra começar já na lua de mel eu
tenho que me isolar num domingo de sol e
fica horas trabalhando por
videoconferência meu irmão do outro lado
da linha
isso aí já era um sinal do que viria
pela frente
no primeiro ano de casamento ela me viu
colocar todo o dinheiro tempo e energia
no projeto de uma startup que por
definição tá inserido num ambiente de
altíssimo risco e ao invés de cobrança
eu via admiração por esse processo
eu também me desenvolver uma ansiedade
que eu nunca tinha visto em mim noite
sem dormir a rotina era a noite o
pensamento vinha como tava empresa que
precisava investir
eu estava muito inquieto porque tinha
muito risco envolvido e assim a empresa
nasceu fechou seus primeiros contratos
eram 11 o início de uma jornada incrível
de altos e baixos
agora por falar em altos e baixos
o ano era 2015 vocês devem se lembrar a
situação econômica e política no brasil
estava muito delicada período pós
eleição que aconteceu o seguinte o nosso
principal cliente cancelou uma ordem de
compra que salvaria o faturamento
daquele ano
a gente ia quebrar eu lembro conversar
com o irmão e agente falar assim a gente
vai cair mas a gente cai atirando ea
decisão foi abrir novos mercados
a gente pensou em conquistar clientes na
europa então eu me vi entrando no avião
com banner debaixo do braço com a logo
da empresa para participar de uma feira
na frança mas nesse momento me vi
entrando na caminhonete como meu pai
fazia enfrentando o medo com poucos
recursos e com um objetivo muito claro
de conquistar clientes com essa viagem
a viagem foi ótima três dias intensos de
trabalho
tive a oportunidade de apresentar a
empresa para diversas pessoas e no final
a gente fechou um contrato com uma
empresa na inglaterra agora pensa num
cara feliz voltando pra casa
o contrato foi assinado nas semanas
seguintes
tudo correndo bem a gente contratou
pessoas para esse projeto primeiro mês
do projeto tudo correndo bem segundo
mesmo deu nem tempo de estourar o
champanhe do terceiro mês
ao invés de pagamento eu recebi uma
carta do banco da inglaterra falando que
a conta bancária daquele cliente tinha
sido bloqueada é mole não receberia um
centavo a gente não quebrou antes agora
a gente quebrar ia mas é nessa hora que
eu volto na minhas referências para
entender que aquela história não
terminaria ali foi necessário entender o
que tinha sido feito de errado e
corrigir os erros e seguir com a empresa
eu já estava pronto de novo para entrar
na caminhonete como meu pai
fazia agora com o modelo de negócio novo
novos produtos novos mercados e hoje eu
vejo que valeu muito a pena de seguido
por que a partir desse momento a empresa
cresceu e já passou por algumas rodadas
de investimento as maiores empresas do
brasil hoje usam nossa plataforma ea
gente treinou um time incrível que eu só
tenho muito orgulho de fazer parte
então eu aprendi com isso que ser
empreendedor é de fato ter muita
resiliência
eu poderia ter acreditado que aquilo não
era pra mim voltado para o mercado
procurando emprego mas um pouco de
insanidade é o que leva o empreendedor
pra frente e tem sido uma jornada
incrível e recentemente eu tive uma
notícia maravilhosa você pai e eu começo
a pensar em que tipo de legado que quero
deixar que tipo de experiência o meu
filho vai ter quando ele passar o meu
caderninho limpa
então eu gostaria de voltar naquele
exercício inicial e propor que aí porém
com um ponto de vista diferente ao invés
da gente pensar na pessoa que mais me
influenciou
vamos pensar em que tipo de referência
eu sou para as pessoas que estão
próximas a mim que tipo de referência eu
posso ser para o meu filho
pensaram eu pensei o seguinte eu quero
que meu filho me veja comemorando a cada
conquista como eu via meu pai
comemorando a cada venda
eu quero que meu filho é um exemplo de
um pai que não desiste do sonho de
empreender
nem quando leva um tombo
quero que meu filho entenda que assim
como ele vai cair muitas vezes antes de
aprender a andar
ele vai errar muitas vezes antes de
seguir o caminho que ele mesmo vai
escolher e que ele terá uma rede de
apoio que ele pode confiar ea força do
exemplo é de fato muito importante nesse
processo mas sinceramente me parece ser
simples afinal de contas uma caminhonete
saindo de madrugada
boas histórias ao fim de cada viagem e
um caderninho passado a limpo
me parece que são suficientes muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]